Amanda identified as a woman having all
the same rights that you have as a
female every single right that you have
as a female would you be happy that a
man who's identified as a woman can just
turn around they've had the operation
I've got all the same rights as you
every single one
all the rights that you have as a female
and they're going to go up against you
as a as a as a
born female as a gender female they're
gonna go up against you in everything
and they expect the same rights as you
as a female all the same rights that you
have as a female but I don't even think
women have such amazing rights anyways
we live in a very misogynistic oh no we
do we do
in terms of when it comes to court cases
they're more likely to get the child but
really what does what does a woman have
women or build up women are literally
built out of every bad decision that we
make like every single one if we sleep
around there's birth control if we if we
get pregnant there's abortion if we
don't want to get abortion if we don't
want if we don't want to get an abortion
and we want to live off of the
government they'll pay for our housing
like literally every bed if we're
homeless there's women's shelters
there's not men's shelters they're just
homeless you're just talking about
abortion so that whoever is that Jenna
whoever he is
if we announce
now that he's pregnant and he wants an
abortion
how would you feel about that
I literally have nothing against that I
just feel like I
that's my life it affects me in no way
did you hear what I said it may not
affect you now
why would it ever affect him
can I ask you a question can I ask a
question exactly can I ask a question
through me do you think that do you
believe that objective truth exists
to an extent yeah
do you think it's important
yeah okay if if as a society we start to
reject objective truths do you think
this leads down to a concerning pathway
at all if we if we categorically reject
objective truth in order to accommodate
the feelings of a very very very tiny
proportion of people do you not see how
that Cascades into many other problems
some of which we've already talked about
but many further down the line which we
probably cannot even fathom at this
point
and that's how it all started yeah right
I would be arguing just as vehemently
about if someone was coming here telling
me that two plus two equals five
I would be arguing as vehemently in
defense of the fact that two plus two
equals four not because I'm super
enthusiastic about mathematics but
simply because it is truth right and to
deny that truth once you break that and
you say that that doesn't matter and
it's more important to allow someone to
make two plus two equals five or for
everybody to accommodate that you've now
the the problems Downstream of that now
are going to be numerous and and
extremely chaotic we're now living in a
world where truth is just being rejected
and if you can do it on one issue you
can do it on many other things
and I mean in terms of like identifies
as an animal I think that is a bit too
much for me why but why there's people
out there isn't that close-minded
why not be a more open-minded they are
completely against it I'm just saying
that it's too much like what no but why
but I think why when it comes to humans
that you want to be another
like type of human I think why not no no
wait wait no wait I'm curious please
explain to me why you think identifying
as another species is too much why
well first of all I guess you can't even
use the reproduce you ah
okay it's just weird it's weird you
don't think it's weird to chop your dick
off
work you don't think that's weird you
can be born with both it just it just
shut up my new number and that's that's
a difference it's not like there's an
amazing stopless amount of transgenders
but the point is they are there just
like you can have a vagina why why do
you think that it's possible that you
can want to change to a woman so it's
like we have to just try and understand
it yeah just say right okay can I just
the percentage of transgender people
they must take a minority
of the world will be giving them so many
rights you but earlier on you mentioned
that's the same as race
look how far forward they're pushing us
before they push the black Grace thing
before the freedom of it look how far
how far how many hundreds of years that
they were saying went to slavery and all
that
but all of a sudden this small minority
is kicking up stink within the last what
10 years they're coming on and
everybody's getting confused and you're
going towards that
um
no it's what that's that's got to that's
to do with power the person with the
most the person with the most power is
going to get what they want but now so
they're one of the least power is
getting what they want because they're
confusing people especially people like
you that so easily molded and easily
make it believable these are the small
minority tiny minority who now was
coming over like they're the majority
and that's the problem because I'm sure
that years ago you weren't thinking like
this all of a sudden you start listening
that's what they want you to do that's
what they want and the fact that they're
confusing the children as well yeah that
is what is paying me off because I'm a
mother of two do you understand she's a
child to me considering my son so as far
as I'm concerned they're starting
confusing the children already otherwise
if she doesn't know who she is what a
woman is
then what chance do we spend for your
children my grandchildren and that's
what it needs to stop because they've
started with like they're older they get
into you and now they want to get into
the school yeah so according to how
you're thinking it should be okay to go
into the schools and to be teaching I
think when the schools will be up
earlier and it was on the news that they
didn't want to teach them sex education
I can't remember what children as young
as five I want to do about transgender
and all these different genders with sex
education it's a joke for school
children and that's what I said to you
earlier on if your child came home and
said well Mom
and I want to be a girl
and as far as and by your way of
thinking
the children in school
everybody should be allowed to feel who
they want to feel they should allow to
be who they want to be so why can't your
son wear a dress and shoes tomorrow and
have his hair in bows and by the way I
hope you know that there are parents in
this country in Canada and in the USA
who have lost custody of their own
children for refusing to affirm their
gender confusion lost custody to their
own children the state the government
has stepped in and taken control of that
situation because they've decided that
because their dad or mom said no you are
not this thing you're saying you are
you're you're confused they've stepped
in under the guise of so-called child
abuse because if they if this is this is
the Gateway that's being open and that's
the way it's going to go and that's the
logical procession
of these ideas so I've said many times
I'm a big defender of people's rights
but your rights do not include the right
to trample other people's rights or the
right to force people to believe things
they don't believe or say things they
don't want to say and so on as soon as
you're trying to do that you're the one
who's out of order because I would never
try to force I have a lot of strong
beliefs in this world right but I am not
trying to force them upon anyone I will
even say so look you are allowed to
believe that you're a man in a woman's
body you're allowed to believe you're a
woman and you're allowed to believe
whatever you want I do not I'm not
compelled you don't have a right to make
me
validate that you you you just don't
right I don't I don't even have a right
like I'm I'm a male I'm a he I don't
have a right to make you call me a he
yeah right like I I can't just say just
like I can't say okay these are the
adjectives I like to be referred by this
is how I see myself I see myself a lot
of ways I identify as many things but
it's up to someone else whether they
want to also agree that they identify me
as those things and to refer to me as
that and so can I just ask are you okay
with homosexuals
what does that mean
a what homosexuals Oh I thought you said
something okay I heard something
different I was like is that a new term
omnise
are you okay with homosexuals what does
that mean that's just what do you mean
okay with it I know what homosexual is
but what do you mean by okay okay so are
they okay to decide that they like
someone of the opposite sex but they
don't affect our life of course they are
it's a free world oh okay so you can be
gay but you can't change your gender
when did I say that
that's what I'm trying to do you
not literally change your sex it's not
possible just like just like you can't
fly you you can't change your sex
it's not possible okay so you define
your gender with the chromosome purely
the chromosomes
yeah it goes beyond chromosomes we've
said you know there there is chromosomes
there's our reproductive or our
reproductive wiring there's our hormonal
profiles there's our physiques
everything from our skeleton to our body
mass and so on there are many
differences between males and females by
the way not just in the human species
across the entire Animal Kingdom it's a
it's a binary thing right every single
person who exists in this world was
Breath by a woman with no exceptions but
that's the same conversation they had
with homosexuals because no let me let
me finish I didn't say because the the
recurring conversation is because a man
and a woman can reproduce so how can you
like someone of the same sex because you
can't reproduce and that's the same
conversation they had this was the um
the defense that people would always say
to them no you're you know it's like
what's the major difference I can
explain easily your sexual preference I
can explain this very easily it's not
even a hard question okay okay
uh homosexual is if a male who is
attracted to males yeah it's a gay man
right a woman who is attracted to a
female who's attracted other females is
a lesbian woman
okay these are these are just objective
okay if a female says that he if a
female says that she is a male or a male
says that that he is a female
that is
you this is not objective reality
they're not even in the same sphere
that's an objective just saying that
you're attracted to some some like your
opposite sex that's not objective that's
something that you actually have to
understand that person and I should be
like no wait why no sexual person there
are other parts it's it's objective
reality that there are men who are
attracted to men and there are women who
are attracted to women because we're so
forward thinking now no no no no no no
no people didn't want to accept that
it's always whether or not they accepted
it it existed
yeah but just like he always existed
transgender always existed now we're
having the conversation no no it didn't
no it doesn't
no the feeling that you feel like you
are gender dysphoria that's gender
dysphoria you want to categorize that's
what it's called that's lit by
definition this is what it's called
transgenderism is gender dysphoria
exists I've said that there are males
who feel like they identify more as the
opposite sex there are females who feel
they identify you know I agree with you
because that exists there's people that
actually Tran um they change into women
and then five years down the line
they're like actually it's the worst
thing I've ever done I want to be a man
now there's a child that is dysphoria
it's a dysphoria
there are people that that's how they
feel and they continue in that life and
I've never see you're the thing is
you're arguing against points I'm not
making I've never at any point said that
someone is not allowed to do that or
someone is not allowed to believe that
or there are not people who genuinely
feel that way yeah I am simply saying
just because you feel you are something
does not make you that thing I can't
just say just because you feel like
you're attracted to the opposite sex no
it's because naturally no naturally you
shouldn't be attracted to the opposite
sex no naturally you should in the Bible
it talks about Adam and Eve even when it
comes here do you think you mean should
yeah you should not yes she even should
oh oh okay yeah okay
okay
attracted to the opposite sex
yeah but like the point the point you're
gonna make is is he's not even
disagreeing with you he's saying there
are people that feel like they should be
met like women that feel like they
should be men and men that feel like
they should be women but throughout
history they couldn't they were they
weren't we didn't have trans there
aren't people doing the surgeries and
stuff yeah so that's that's a news yeah
or the hormones that's a new thing so we
should thank God that now we have the
technology to do that should we
are you in a relationship right now no
okay
Place yourself in a relationship with a
man your dream man your dream man dream
house dream whole thing right
and
you're planning a wedding kids you're
like I've got my dream life
and he turned around to you at dinner
one night and said
I feel that I I'm getting feelings that
I identify more as a woman
and I am going to
pursue looking at
um you know speaking I don't know
speaking to a therapist and potentially
getting surgery
um will you support me and stay with me
and can we still have a family
what Would You Do Well I wouldn't stay
with him because I'm not attracted I I
like straight extra sexual men I mean
whatever yeah but you just said you just
said hang on hang on you just said you
just said that we have to be more
accepting we have to understand
so this is your this is your boyfriend
I'm not saying that you're saying you
don't have to understand him but you
have to understand
him and not be sexually attracted to him
I can say you know what I'm gonna be I'm
gonna help you be a part of this process
Actually I don't even help him okay I
have a question I have a question I have
a question what if are we gonna ask the
same question
so you said you're attracted to straight
eight men what if this man that's
transitioning to a woman still likes
women he's still considered a straight
man
so would you stay but I like a man that
looks like a woman is not going to look
like a woman because to me tell you what
a man that looks like a man you mean
what if he has like short yeah I'm just
like a bob doesn't wear makeup natural
look still looks like a man was like
identifies a woman
so what's making your woman if you're
not trying to look like a woman feeling
you tell me it feels it just feels that
way well you told me it's not about
looks you told us it's not about looks
to look like a woman if he's saying you
know what I'm I still look like a man
and I Feel Like a Woman
I guess because I see you as a man I
can't really I guess the sexual
attraction is still there so what if
okay I have a question so what if
you're dating a guy okay you're super
happy same situation right and instead
of him transitioning he tells you I used
to be a girl oh that was another
question do you care you probably would
have noticed but yeah yeah
guys he had the best surgery it's
because I want to understand him does
not mean I'm attracted to it it doesn't
mean sexually I want to be with someone
like that it just means I'm okay with
you experimenting understanding but
that's the same thing zubi was saying
he's saying I don't care what you do you
can do what the hell ever you want but
that doesn't make what you're doing real
so so and I think and I think and I
think on some level you know this and
this is and like I just I don't know if
you like to argue or what because
because you know deep down that Bruce
like Bruce Jenner Caitlyn do whatever it
is didn't deserve that award like
there's something in you that knows this
you know but but it's like you're you
just like to argue I don't know what it
is
it seems like either you know some trans
people and you're worried about
affecting maybe you've got some friends
that are Trend or you know trans people
and that you're frightened um do you
know where it is I feel like because
we're in a podcast already and we've
kind of touched on this subject and we
got a lot of backlash for it because I
was more outspoken about it but Esther
was more like sitting on the fence about
it you know like oh no no so I feel like
she's trying to protect people's
feelings that's what I feel like you're
not actually speaking your truth
I'll be honest this is probably the and
I'm gonna be completely honest I grew up
in a very Christian traditional home I
remember when I was deeply into God I
used to tell homosexuals that basically
they go into hell and honestly back then
I believe that that was the truth you
are going to hell because you are
basically attracted to someone of the
same sex and I remember someone I was in
school with I I used to upset him a lot
and I didn't realize how upset he was
because of the worst I say to him but I
couldn't help it because I'd go to
church my pastor would stop preaching
about homosexuals and how can I have a
question when did your mind um Kazooie
kind of asked us earlier but when did
your mind change on this stuff I would
say maybe one
and I started to think about was it in
University possibly
um no I actually went I went to China
actually I remember going to China and
in China the major thing that they have
is they renounce all religion so they
don't um they're basically are against
Christians Muslim all that and I think I
liked the way that everyone was so yeah
I don't care and I think that re because
I was with a lot of like Christians
Muslim and they were all like yeah
Christian is the right way and they were
like no it's Allah and I really thought
that was quite ignorant to not listen to
people and think your way is the right
way and I think it made me start to
really take things back to and I thought
about that guy that I really upset
because that was generally my truth but
then now I look back at here as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible